[Music]
your weight from your coma hallelujah in
the miracle baby who was this book oh I
pray now oh yes and I say my rosary
think you were in this coma a lot has
changed find this just divorce papers
how do you expect me to marry the love
of my life without a divorce from you
hey baby look I'm turning on snapchat oh
that's great baby because we'll be
chatting about my snaps tonight oh yeah
what what is snapchat old is that good
don't you worry about it he gave me
three beautiful children more than what
you could do he gave you children seems
very quick Oh baby we're supposed to
stay together forever like Brad and
Angie oh honey
they even split up well at least they're
gonna be shared custody those kids I
know that for a fact because there is a
lot of love in that house actually
Angelina wants full custody is the
perfect yoga we grow up breakups happen
now sign the damn papers yeah I'll sign
these damn papers but it is gonna take a
lot of one direction ballads to get over
these two breakups naughty one direction
broke up too
oh hell to the naw wake your ass up you
know stare better use wise yes steal
you